blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman let's start today with an update
on how the pandemic is going in the
united states and around the world this
is probably the
the least good update that we've had
in a couple of months but it does
require some thought and some
explanation and there's some details to
understand
so the the top line like the bad number
the number going in the wrong direction
is cases
cases per day in the united states and
around the world
are now climbing once again and after
more than two months of declines and
significant declines for much of that
two two and a half month period
average daily cases are again ticking up
not by that much but from a low of about
55
000 new cases a day in the united states
now up about five percent to 58
000 cases per day remember context
these are numbers many in 2020 thought
we would never get to
we blew past them all the way up to 255
000 cases per day came back down
and now we're back up from 55 000 to 58
000. what is driving this we're
vaccinating
uh we're vaccinating millions per day at
this point and we'll look at those
numbers
how is it that cases are again going up
couple of different things going on one
is that in some
states the more contagious british
variant
known as b117 is becoming more
widespread now remember that
the vaccines work really well against
b117
but among unvaccinated people it's going
to spread more
that's exactly what is happening for
example in michigan michigan
is a place where b117 is becoming more
widespread
as the variant of of dominance
and michigan's cases aren't just ticking
up slightly they're skyrocketing
primarily again among unvaccinated
people michigan cases are
up 250 percent from a recent
uh low so the other aspect of this is
is more of a sort of uh i guess you'd
call it a psychological aspect in a
sense
as people learn about vaccination
and they hear that people are getting
vaccinated and they hear that cases are
coming down
some people choose to behave less safely
and there's an analogy here to something
that traffic engineers deal with when
traffic engineers
look at a stretch of highway or road for
example that has a lot of traffic and
they say we need more lanes in order to
better accommodate traffic
they will start a project to widen a
road
and of course people learn about the
fact that the road is going to be
widened and will have more capacity
and often what happens is that by the
time that the road
is widened increasing capacity
more people because they have heard hey
this road will have more capacity
so traffic will go down more people
choose to use the road
and so by the time that the road is done
you have more capacity but traffic is
moving just as slowly because more
people are choosing to use the road
similarly we are seeing spring breakers
in florida
states rolling back all guidelines etc
as cases started to come down because
vaccination
was going up and the seasonality effect
more people are behaving less
less responsibly less safely i guess we
would say and thus we are starting to
see
cases tick back up now despite cases
going up
the good news is that deaths continue to
decline for now as we know at this point
deaths lag cases by about three weeks
we're already three weeks out from cases
leveling
deaths continue to decline from their
peak of about
nearly 3 500 a day towards the
middle to end of january now down to
about a thousand deaths a day that is a
decline of 70 percent
but the decline the rate of decline is
slowing down
and one signal that might not bode so
well
is in terms of people going into the
hospital
new hospitalizations have also continued
down
but the rate of decline is slowing down
significantly so this is a crucial
period of about i would say
two to three months is what most of the
epidemiologists say
it's a battle of vaccination versus
variants
and we have very good data about how
good the vaccines are
i read yesterday a study uh which
tracked
california healthcare workers after
being vaccinated and what the study
found was that
the fully vaccinated healthcare workers
meaning 14 days out from dose number two
something like 0.05 percent
became infected this is a group that's
highly exposed
working in health care settings around
unvaccinated
sick patients very low rate of contagion
among those who are vaccinated so that's
the good
news vaccination is now averaging right
around 2.5 million doses per day
that's a combination of two dose
vaccines and single dose
johnson and johnson uh total 2.5 million
doses per day that number
should continue to grow it appears that
it is going to continue to grow but this
is not a good time to start going crazy
the way we've seen
spring breakers do in florida so super
zoomed out
vaccinations up deaths down that's good
medium term hospitalizations leveling
out
not declining that quickly lately cases
up
and vaccine distribution in much of the
world
not good and ultimately i mean to really
get back to normal
as a global village for lack of a better
term
other countries are going to need to do
well on vaccination there are countries
not expected to get
significant access to vaccines until
2023
maybe wouldn't even fully vaccinate
until 2024 who knows what variants we'll
be on to by then so
that this is a bigger issue now we're
starting to hear
you know more about a vaccine equity and
and countries like the us and the uk
hoarding vaccines and different issues
as i've said before
i think it's perfectly natural that
countries would try to vaccinate
their own people first but there is no
question
that until there is more vaccine
distribution globally
we are not going to be able to say that
we have we have dealt with
the pandemic but let's keep vaccinating
uh
all you can do here in the us is when
you can get a vaccine get one
that's what you can do we have been
hearing more and more over the last
several
weeks to month and a half or so
republicans in right-wing media pushing
the narrative of
a crisis at the border and a surge
in undocumented crossings last week we
covered house minority
leader republican congressman kevin
mccarthy
who staged an event at the u.s mexico
border
said unaccompanied minors are coming to
the u.s
in crisis levels and the crisis was
caused by joe biden
kevin mccarthy said that terrorists are
coming in
through the u.s mexico border from yemen
turkey and wait yemen turkey and iran
it was there was no actual evidence of
that but this is the narrative it's been
pushed by fox news reporters during
press briefings it's been pushed
in news reports it's been pushed by
republicans at press conferences
is this real well the washington post
analyzed border patrol data going back
to 2012
and there appears to be no crisis
whatsoever there is no
surge that we could link to biden
administration policy
what we are seeing is data that tracks a
seasonal pattern this is the time of
year
where there are more migrants attempting
to cross and interacting with border
patrol
plus some what we might call pent-up
demand
from the covet period last year when
movement was just dramatically reduced
so if we look at a chart of encounters
per month
at the border looking at the last few
years and we're putting that up on the
screen
what you see is that numbers went up at
exactly this time of year in 2019
they did not in 2020 because of the
pandemic
they went up slightly at this time in
2018
and that's the pattern it's a pattern
that's been observed for some time now
yes apprehended migrants are up 28
from january to february but apprehended
migrants were up 31
during the same period in 2019 it is
true
that the raw numbers are higher right
now than last year
and the year before remember movement
in general went down during the pandemic
so what you're seeing
number one right now is a resumption of
movement and number two some backed up
demand from people who did not move
around last year
now let me be very clear because i know
i'm going to get emails about this i'm
not saying we don't need total and
complete immigration reform we do
uh this doesn't mean uh that joe biden
has done enough to stop deportations he
hasn't
and i've talked about that it simply is
not the crisis that republicans want you
to think it is it's the crisis that
we've had in this country for a long
time
combined with a lack of comprehensive
immigration reform which i and others
have been calling for
for just as long of a time what trump
did last year with title 42 which is uh
using the pandemic as a reason um to
turn people around and deport it seems
to have delayed
people from coming not stopped people
from coming
period that's the story many of them are
coming now
not because joe biden is president but
because the pandemic is to some degree
easing almost identical to joe biden's
surge in gas prices last week which we
covered earlier this week
we are seeing gas prices go up it's not
because of joe biden
they started going up in october when
donald trump was still president
and what we're seeing is demand for
gasoline
recover as the pandemic starts to ease
it has nothing to do with joe biden
so serious media should really just
report this
based on facts but without using the
language that the right uses you know
when you talk about border crisis it's
sort of like sleepy joe and china virus
these are terms that the right uses to
frame the debate in a particular way
where you're no longer questioning
whether there is a border crisis
you're merely arguing as to whose fault
it is and
to what degree it exists and this is how
the right
does really well at framing issues it
keeps republican voters enraged
it doesn't really allow solutions to the
problems however
so call it a predictable seasonal
pattern that we've observed for a decade
bolstered by the waning of coronavirus
to some degree
and um even non like what we
even what we would call non-right-wing
media
is using a lot of the terms of the right
when they talk about this and as i've
talked about before using their
don't let them even set the agenda and
narrative by using the language and
that's what they
successfully have done on so many issues
for decades as we've talked about with
people like
george lakoff and thomas frank here on
the program so don't fall for it
here's the data the data's clear and
and we're going to continue to track
that data tomorrow
friday finally the day is here the one
day
david pakman show membership special we
are doing a massive blowout of
memberships we're hoping for massive
membership dumps tomorrow
if you want to be notified of a one day
i i hesitate to even say that it's a
moral discount i believe the discount
we're offering tomorrow is immoral it's
vaccine themed if you want to be
notified tomorrow morning
just get on my newsletter at
davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long and
other things got in the way and it was
fantastic to check it out on blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
never forget that the david pakman
show's primary source of revenue
is not a money tree on which dollar
bills
and half dollar coins grow uh
it's not big corporate sponsorships it's
mostly just people like you viewers and
listeners who sign up at joinpakman.com
so consider yourself invited grab a
membership at joinpakman.com you can
also join the discussion on the david
pakman show
subreddit which you can find at
davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t nearly
30 000 of our viewers and listeners are
now subscribed
free to the david pakman show subreddit
some interesting posts
i like this one someone posted to
david's will never see on fox news again
me after my last fox news appearance
and david leopold the immigration
attorney who we covered earlier this
week
who called out fox host judge janine
pirro
over the weekend uh i think that is fair
to say
i don't think i will ever be back on fox
news actually you know
i don't know that i don't think i'll be
back on the weekend news hours
the fox fox really you know each show is
its own thing i think it's plausible
that i'd be back on some other show but
i don't think they'll have me back on
the weekend america's news headquarters
after my last appearance
and yes i don't think david leopold is
going to be back on fox news
anytime soon user portland hipster
suggests that i start referring to
donald trump
as a former one-term president trump and
that it will
trigger quote right-wing cucks yeah i
think that the syntax
former one-term president trump um
the i think that it makes more sense to
say the one-term
former president donald trump or just
the one-term president
donald trump um yeah i like that idea i
think that that's definitely an
adjustment that uh
i i would easily be able to make on the
show when referring to donald trump
and then user a what the cheese
posted about anti-vaxx math pointing out
that
the us has seen 30 million dollars i'm
sorry 30 million dollars
30 million confirmed coronavirus cases
the real number could be anywhere up to
you know two to three times higher than
that 550 000 coveted deaths
125 million vaccine doses administered
now it's closer to 130.
1900 vaccinated people that died
and no one that we know of who has died
from the vaccine
and yet anti-vaxxers somehow seem to
think
that the vaccine might be more dangerous
to them than coronavirus yeah of course
the math
doesn't work and what you have to also
remember even about
so there's a lot here that's even
understated right we have no
deaths linked to the vaccine that's true
but even deaths of people who died after
being vaccinated
when you vaccinate tens of millions of
people
by sheer math some of the vaccinated
people will die
from an actuarial perspective of old age
of other conditions etc so um
i i think that it's very important to
put this math in perspective it's also
important to remember you know on
anti-vaxx math
what else are anti-vaxxers scrutinizing
to the degree that they claim to be
scrutinizing vaccines and ingredients in
this type of thing
i mean do they ever eat junk food do
they understand what all of the elements
are
in junk food on the ingredient list when
they buy
shampoo when they buy skin creams and
toothpaste and whatever
are are they scrutinizing the um
uh uh i don't know if they're called
ingredients when it comes to health and
beauty products but
are they scrutinizing everything that is
in those products to this degree
there's definitely a uh it's sort of
like
sometimes people become uh there's this
thing orthorexia
where people become fixated on diet to a
degree that that's unhealthy it's almost
like a diagnosable
condition and you start to wonder you
know
what else do you obsess about to this
degree in your life
outside of your diet and maybe we should
apply some context i think the same
thing applies to many anti-vaxxers where
great you're really concerned about um
what's what's in the vaccines that's
fine
are you equally concerned when you get
antibiotics are you equally equally
concerned when you buy tylenol are you
equally concerned when you look at junk
food
have have you ever looked at the
ingredients in zebra cakes
uh and i'm kind of half kidding maybe
zebra cakes don't have anything that
crazy in them i used to love those as a
kid i really did
zebra cakes anyway join the discussion
um on the david pakman show subreddit
davidpakman.com
reddit i have for you today possibly
the dumbest segment in newsmax history
newsmax is one of these
sort of like a lower rent fox news more
extreme by the way if you can imagine
and this was an interview that two
newsmax hosts
did with dick morris i have to tell you
dick morris is kind of a sad
character at this point dixon is mid-70s
now he's not super present publicly
but dick morris was like a big clinton
friend in the early 90s
who eventually had a falling out with
the clintons turned against the clintons
but also became kind of a right-wing
apologist i won't necessarily say he is
a right-winger
although after watching this interview
it sounds like he is but certainly a
right-wing apologist
i interviewed dick morris a few years
ago he hated my line of questioning so
much
that he hung up on me you can find that
interview on my youtube channel
so dick morris appears on newsmax right
after the colorado shooting now first of
all
the segment this segment existing at all
aside from what dick says which we will
look at
the segment existing is part of the
silliness newsmax and fox and others
they've been covering the colorado
shooting where we found out the shooter
is muslim
totally differently than the georgia
shooting where the shooter is white and
the victims
were minorities but i'm for this segment
i'm putting aside
the structural hypocrisy and we're going
to focus just on what is said
during the interview so let's jump right
in and look at the first clip
murderers and their willingness to
continually
make excuses for them to
your thoughts well
there's a overwhelming point here which
is that
uh the killer was a syrian refugee
and donald trump banned refugees
from terror-sponsoring countries like
syria and donald and joe biden has
opened the floodgates again letting them
in and in fact with specifically
earmarking refugees
he's increased the number of refugees
that can come into the us
by a factor of seven or eight so dick
morris's argument
is that the shooter in colorado is
exactly the type of person that donald
trump
banned from the united states but joe
biden is now welcoming to the united
states
the colorado shooter was three years
old when he came to the united states he
was radicalized
in the united states or he became you
know uh
if we want to go the mental illness
route he he he
developed his condition in the united
states and
is essentially an american i mean look i
came to the us when i was five
so i was two years older than the
colorado shooter my
upbringing has been shaped here
my education is mostly in the united
states
my political views my interests my
social circle it's all been shaped here
the colorado shooter was
even younger than i was when he came to
the united states
what on earth does this have to do with
syria or
donald trump's ban or joe biden and if
you can believe it it gets even dumber
let's continue
the other point i want to make is if the
democrats are so worried about
gun violence the the most important
thing you can do about gun violence
is to institute the stop and frisk
policy that new york city had until the
democrats
forced it to be out to be stopped okay
so now dick morris says
let's use stop and frisk we're talking
about
mass shootings here individual gun
homicides handgun stuff
okay like you can you can talk about
stop and frisk of course the problem
with stop and frisk as we saw in new
york is
its application was extremely racially
biased but
this segment is about the causes of a
mass shooting
that took place with a rifle does dick
think that police will stop mass
shootings with rifles
with stop and frisk where police just
stumble across a random guy with a
gigantic rifle in his pants on his way
to a mass shooting
it's ridiculous and then it gets even
more ridiculous
where the cop actually sees somebody on
the street
with a gun in a high crime area very
late at night
and can stop them and see if they're
armed if they're not they let them go
if they are they get they get arrested
for a mandatory three-year sentence
for carrying a loaded firearm in the
city of new york now did you hear what
dick said there
stop and frisk is where police can stop
someone if they see them walking around
with a gun that's not stop and frisk
that's you see someone with a gun and
you inquire as to the legal status of
the gun
but then dick says they frisk them and
if they have a gun they get arrested but
dick you just said stop and frisk is
police see someone with a gun and they
stop them but now you're saying stop and
frisk is
if they have a gun after you frisk them
you arrest them it's making no sense
and of course its application to mass
shootings is zero
let's look at a little more of this and
this is funny because the host actually
says
the colorado shooter was only three when
he moved to the u.s
it doesn't slow dick morris down even
one for a moment
yeah you know um ahmad al-alissa he uh
moved here to this country when he was
just three years old
uh but because of some recent activity
of his
he was actually on the the spectrum of
the fbi
so this is another case that the fbi was
aware of him
or at least people near him and watching
him
but yet this was still allowed to happen
that's another conversation a lot of
folks aren't having
yes well i think the the point is that
he comes from a country
that sponsors terrorism syria his
parents didn't brought him here at a
young age but
that is precisely the kind of immigrant
that joe biden is letting in
and donald trump wanted to bar so dick
morris hears the kid was
three when he came to the u.s and the
fbi was aware of him
but he's sticking with this is why we
don't let syrians
into the country so the real story there
is that yet again the fbi has their eye
on someone
and that individual still can get guns
more easily than you can register to
vote in some states with a waiting
period on voter registration right there
are states
where you can't register and vote on the
same day you have to register in advance
and later vote but you can decide
same day to go get a gun and walk out of
the store with it that
that day on the fbi's radar and still
was able to do that
but dick morris says the problem is
i guess we don't have stop and frisk and
the kid came from syria when he was
three
and that relates to joe biden in some
way i have to tell you
dick morris has become sort of a sad
figure in politics
and newsmax allowing him to also
expose his incompetence only makes it
sadder
but making no sense whatsoever and the
news max host standing aside and letting
him do it
we'll have more on this and i would love
your reaction you can follow us
on instagram at david pakman show and
we will have maybe we'll have a uh an
additional clip of this interview
it's really something to see find us on
instagram at david pakman show
find me on instagram david.pakman
the number one funding source for the
david pakman show
has been and continues to be membership
and membership is not just a feel-good
thing
you get access to the world-famous bonus
show every single day
just for members as well as commercial
free audio
and video feeds of the show day in
and day out you can sign up for
membership very very quickly
at joinpackman.com that's join p
a pakman.com if the normal prices strike
you as high
by all means use the coupon code
better21
all one word all lowercase become a
member today
today we're welcoming back an old friend
of the show
ben dixon host of the benjamin dixon
show
ben always great to have you david it's
always a pleasure glad to be back
so okay i mean how's joe biden doing so
far
you know that's a big question i
i feel like it's a loaded question but
you know if you if you actually are
dealing fairly with joe biden he's had
some good and he's had some bad
yeah i am um there are a lot of people
who are
really grateful to have the uh the
stimulus checks
um and while it wasn't as much as we
wanted it to be
and while it wasn't it didn't include 15
an hour it still
helped a lot of people and there are
some good things in it right there's uh
the the attack that they have owned
poverty right this bill is supposed
to cut child childhood poverty by 42 to
45 percent
we'll see how that does so i have to
give them thumbs up on that even though
it's not
everything i think is really beneficial
so one of the big things that was
missing from the stimulus bill
was the 15 minimum wage my view on this
is that the problem is that the senate
democrat the group of senate democrats
just isn't left enough it's not that
kamala didn't
push the parliament override the
parliamentarian because
we saw with the vote that democrats just
didn't have the votes for 15
minimum wage so for me it's less about
oh
joe and kamala backed off by not
overriding
it's there aren't enough democrats in
the senate who want a 15
minimum wage do you see it that way or
do you think they should have pushed the
par
overridden the parliamentarian yeah no i
definitely think they should have
overridden the parliamentarian if for no
other reason than to
give us the fight that that we wanted
and that we needed on that issue however
you're not wrong
because then it would have been um
kirsten cinema
uh joe manchin yeah and the other six
who sabotages before and and so but that
does speak to a bigger broader problem
like we
are going to have to send more
progressive leaning senators
there to get things done and they
absolutely
are going to need to overturn or abolish
the filibuster or at least
amend it if they want to get anything
done going forward yeah i want to talk
about filibuster but just to play out
the overriding in practice we got the
vote on including the minimum wage
anyway so we have a record of who voted
no
wouldn't the override just have created
the fight
but in the in the end just delayed
getting people the cash
well you know it depends on the timing
of it like it could have delayed it a
little bit further but also
it would have it really would have shown
and and again
you make a great point we know the eight
people who opposed it
um but then also it would have been it
would have been a little bit more
pressure because
at that point it could come down to a uh
it came down to the 50 vote
versus what they needed in terms of the
60. so it gives them an opportunity
to it really gave the democrats an
out in the long run and it leaves the
suspicion that
perhaps they didn't want to do it anyway
right but that's in the weeds
and like again there are a lot of people
who are just grateful to have
these checks because it took i mean
we're we're so far into this pandemic
and 1600 versus 2 000 15
an hour a lot of people want it we can
come back to it but absolutely
i mean we i'm glad they got it done yeah
if it had not happened
probably within five to seven days of
when it did it probably
goes on a list of failures for joe biden
no absolutely because
you know if the the clock was ticking
the same you know my side of the
equation we were putting pressure on him
from
everywhere like we wanted 15 an hour and
we wanted those checks back in january
yeah you know so you know they they did
what they could do
and there's still enough good things in
that bill that i think are going to have
structural impacts
especially on childhood poverty i can't
overestimate that or overstate that
because that's a really significant move
and they're making they're giving us
signals that they want that
to continue even after this bill has um
run its course so filibuster there's
the option of eliminating the filibuster
with the pros and cons that come with
that
including what happens the next time
that republicans are in control
there's the idea of reform of the
filibuster like for example requiring it
to be an
actual talking filibuster rather than
popping in
and extending debate and then and then
leaving there's the idea of
you need 40 in the chamber to
do it rather than the absence of
60 keeps it going where are you kind of
coming down
on this debate right now you know i
for all intents and purposes the
willingness to even from joe manchin the
willingness to at least admin the
filibuster so that it is
at a minimum a talking filibuster um
is a positive signal however there are
just so many
impediments to to the actual progress
that needs to happen immediately
especially coming from georgia
like we absolutely are going to have to
pass some type of voting rights
legislation it's gotta i know we already
have hr one in the house it's gotta pass
the senate
and the republican party absolutely will
use a talking filibuster
and they will stuff it out in order to
kill that bill
so i think while it is encouraging that
they want to amend it at a minimum
i don't know that a standing filibuster
is going to be enough
to actually beat back the uh the desires
of republicans to suppress the vote
across the country yeah i tend to agree
with you and actually this
in thinking about a lot of the possible
big
uh initiatives that joe biden is
considering so last week we heard
maybe the next big thing will be the tax
reform plan right
this week we heard it might be a three
trillion dollar infrastructure plus
schools and families
um now there's a lot more discussion
about gun control
in light of the two shootings on most of
these things
i'm expecting republican support to not
be close to zero to be
literally zero given that
how should how should joe biden and
democrats even account for that in
thinking of what to approach next
no i i think they honestly are going to
have to play hardball
and of course see the the fear of the
republicans uh mitch mcconnell did that
a couple of videos uh twice making
threats about what they would do
if the filibuster is abolished i think
the
response to that from democrats should
be abolish a filibuster and run campaign
ads
every single day letting americans know
exactly what republicans want to do if
they ever get back in power
so i think they're gonna have to play
some serious hardball and leverage the
actual majority in this country to
ensure
that they don't get back in power in the
near future one of the things i've been
thinking about
is trying to get out of like our
politics bubble where we follow this
stuff in a way that most people don't
and thinking like for example the debate
around whether
covid cash passes with 60 or with 50.
right no one who was waiting on the 1400
cares that it passed with 50 instead of
60 right
and along the same lines when you think
about something like gun control
we know gun control is less of a voting
issue for people on the left
than it is for people on the right the
right weaponizes it whether or not joe
biden's doing anything they're saying
biden's coming for your guns either way
absolutely
uh taxation as an example the narrative
of bidens raising your taxes even if
they're not really going up for 98
of households or whatever the case may
be do you think that joe biden should be
thinking about
which of his ideas are voting issues
versus which are not or should he just
be doing
what he thinks he can get done actually
that's a
really a really great question and thank
you it is 1400 versus the 1600
i i honestly think that he needs to just
simply strike
at what is going to be the best interest
of the people
because this is a really good time where
what he does that's in the best interest
for the majority of the american people
is actually really good politics even if
you do have the republicans on the other
side of the aisle who are going to
weaponize literally anything
they're going to call him a socialist
when he's far from that
they're going to say he's coming to take
their guns when he's not going to take
their guns we're talking about like a
universal background check which you
know we're talking about issues that
have like 90
approval rating in some categories so
you know he needs to
play hardball with them and make his
appeal to the american people in a very
direct way
they need to communicate it they need to
go across the country and make sure
i know we're in a pandemic but they need
to make sure they take credit for all
the good things that they're going to do
because if they don't republicans will
will vote against it and then try to
take credit for it
so on immigration immigration to me
feels like if you watch the press
briefings and you see
how reporters some reporter even even
not right-wing reporters are
adopting the language that's been
established by republicans about a
crisis
at the border we looked at the border
patrol data
seasonally this is when crossings go up
you also have some kind of pent-up
demand from 2020 where there was very
little movement because of the pandemic
so
it all seems in the range of what you
would expect seasonally
crisis to me is is the wrong word but i
think they realize
they're getting the most traction with
it and so that's why they're continuing
to go with it
kamala harris now is being put in charge
of of handling
what's going on at the border what
exactly
what are the options even for what joe
biden could and should be doing there
you know in despite his
options because it is a complicated
issue and it is a matter of capacity and
the speed with which they can actually
move particularly children through the
system and make sure the children are
not there longer than they're supposed
to be there
there is a very nuanced and problematic
issue there at the border in terms of
processing and logistics there is no
crisis though
and i appreciate you stating that
because even we saw msnbc
they're they're using this language joe
scarborough has started using this
language
and it is a throwback to the obama
administration when this is literally
the number one way they wanted to attack
president obama because it does
gain traction and it plays well with the
conservative base
but that goes to the the right-wing
inherent right-wing framing that we get
from mainstream media anyway
right and the irony of it is of course
these headlines were not
being promulgated during the trump
administration
right when the numbers i'm sure if we
look at the numbers there's going to be
some overlap in terms of comparability
but now it is a talking point because
this is all they have
this is what they're going to do and so
we need to look at the we need to
question these mainstream media outlets
that are now shifting to the same
paradigm
where they are creating a crisis with
their headlines versus the reality of
the data
yeah to me the the crisis language
that's being used
is not that different than china virus
and sleepy joe
in the sense that the way you describe
it
is what frames it even for people who
are
questioning what peter ducey says during
you know the gensake press briefings or
whatever the case may be
but for me so far if you say what's the
biggest mistake joe biden has made or
the biggest failure
it's that yes he did do the executive
order on removals and deportations
and then the texas judge said no the the
justification is no good
and biden's not done anything since when
i've read a lot of really good legal
analyses that are
biden could redo those executive orders
to stop that
with different legal justifications and
really put
courts in a position to say none of
these justifications are valid
he just did one executive order and has
kind of stepped away for now
i i don't like that that's for me one of
the biggest things i think he's done
wrong
yeah yeah i think that that would be one
of the number one things the
the number two thing is the willingness
to confront the issue head on for the
difficulty that it actually is
i think jinsaki doesn't really do um
a really good service to the
administration by trying to prevaricate
around the complexity of the situation
versus
simply saying that we don't have the
capacity that we need to actually
get these children out of these cages as
soon as we you know it's just really
direct language is really necessary at
this point
because if if they're prevaricating too
much
then we're going to see these images and
it's not just going to be the right it's
going to be a lot of people on the left
and justifiably so because if we see
these images
we may not know the the technical
difference between what's happening
right now and what happened during the
trump administration what we see are
people in cages and i think they have to
just do the very difficult job of being
straightforward
and expanding the capacity don't just
tell us the truth
help us change the structural problems
that are underneath it one of the things
i would like to see
would be to see jen saki better prepared
to lay it out and say listen
the system we were handed was a disaster
already
we want to fix it but that will require
quote growing government but the
republicans are also
against that so the only way to do what
they want us to do
is by expanding resources hiring more
people
maybe in the short term having more
facilities but they also say we need
small government so
how is it that they expect it to be
fixed if we can't do any of the things
that need to be done
she doesn't she sometimes will say it's
complex but she'll never really frame it
in those terms
right so and and then trust the american
people to handle the complexity right
now i know that's asking a lot all that
is considered but have you seen the
interviews with anti-vaxx people
i know i know complexity is not playing
well right now well but complexity will
will do well for the people who are
actually genuinely concerned about yeah
right
you're going to have bad faith actors on
both sides of the equations that no
matter what this administration does
they're going to get attacked for it
that said there are some of us who
actually are simply concerned about
making sure that not it's not even just
about keeping promises
but we're doing the absolute best that
we can for the human lives that come and
seek asylum in this country
and so for those of us who are operating
in good faith we can handle a moment of
complexity versus
you know kind of dancing around the
issue have you been surprised
by how effective uh the right-wing media
apparatus
and republicans are at getting an idea
to trickle all the way down to what i
would call
random republican voters in diners in
oklahoma like when cnn goes in and they
do it they interview diners in oklahoma
or
in idaho or whatever and ideas that
start with like
you know jim jordan and lauren bobert
and fox and friends
about either a crisis at the border or
stuff about
mandatory vaccine whatever it gets so
quickly to just
random republican voters in oklahoma who
just accept it
yeah you know it's it's a continuation
of the same echo chamber that they've
mastered over the last 40 years i mean
it used to start with rush limbaugh and
now
it you know it's being regurgitated from
through social media and
on youtube like youtubers have the same
talking points
uh people on twitter have the same
talking points i mean
randoms like and here's the other side
of it uh david
you now actively have citizens through
social media
contributing to and seeking out those
talking points so that they can have
something to say to their aunt that they
don't like who's a liberal
on social media so they're they're
they're indoctrinating and
propagandizing themselves what's funny
about that is
for the last at least four years but
arguably longer
the republican party has not been about
policy but it's been about
preventing the left from doing anything
and making the left look bad
that's almost the ideology now of the
random republican voter at thanksgiving
who
is not so much interested in policy but
in about what can i say
to embarrass my liberal cousin or
whatever the case may be yeah
no it's very personalized politics at
this point and it's it's
the analogy of football teams couldn't
be any truer because they're special
pleading on behalf i mean
they they don't care that it's illogical
they don't care if it's downright a lie
they just need something so that they
can post to own the libs
and uh then if it turns out that it's
disinformation not allowed on social
media
the fact that they're not allowed to
post it oh yeah it becomes part of the
story that they talk
yeah no absolutely there's no greater
grievance than a conservative who has
been
flagged for uh propaganda uh
that that um that will be interesting to
follow also actually during during the
biden administration good one last thing
on this i've been thinking
okay so they want to solve cancel
culture is there any quote
solution that is not incredibly
authoritarian
uh government involvement in private
business
i i mean they're oh you mean for them to
solve exactly when they say we need to
fix cancel culture on social media
how do they imagine it being done
without regulating the hell
out of these platforms in a way that
they claim to oppose
you know i think what they really want
is just to be able to use the n word and
not get in trouble i think that would
i think that's their standard so maybe
if you allow that they'll
they'll forgive the other side that's
the end of cancer culture for them they
want to be able to say anything they
want to say without any responsibility
so i i mean the amount of government
that would be required
to come into you know private
corporations
private jobs and and to manage no
responsibility for
it's just a mess thinking about it yeah
it's they want freedom from the
consequences of speech even if it's
someone else's speech that that is the
consequence
absolutely we've been speaking with ben
dixon host of the benjamin dixon show
you can find him on
of course youtube occasionally on tyt
where where else what's your like main
hub right now would you say
i would say my main hub is uh the
podcast format is still one of the
strongest sides so anywhere you get
podcasts i heart radio
spotify all those places were there ben
always great having you on
hey thanks for having me david
the david pakman show is audience
supported media and you can contribute
any amount you want on patreon as little
as one dollar per month
plus you can get the daily bonus show
world famous
at this point and the daily commercial
free tv show
by making those pledges at patreon.com
david pakman show this is audience
supported media we depend on the support
of our viewers and listeners
whether you listen to the podcast watch
on youtube or watch us
on tv or even listen on the radio
patreon.com
davidpakmanshow we now have video
footage
from the january 6th trump riots in
washington dc
which confirmed that a close ally of
radical republican congresswoman
marjorie taylor greene
was not only there but he was inside the
capitol building you might remember that
we previously
discussed that a gentleman named
anthony aguero was suspected of being
inside the capitol building and aguero
is a
known associate of marjorie taylor
greens he's a right-wing
i guess we'd call him like a right-wing
live streamer and activist
and when back in february cnn asked him
were you actually inside the capitol
building on january 6th
he didn't answer and he said you know
there have been videos posted
which i was supposedly filming from
inside the building but they were really
filmed by someone else he sort of played
coy and didn't answer
we now have videos of the riot in which
it is clear that aguero was personally
inside the capitol building
in the screenshot that we're putting up
on the screen from freedom news
tv you see aguero highlighted by a red
circle
on the left side of the screen clearly
inside the capitol building now aguero
has declined to comment on this
marjorie taylor green's office has not
yet responded to requests for comment
but this is now it's no longer
hypothesis it's no longer speculation
it's no longer theory
this is a confirmed trump rioter
who is also an associate of a current
pro-trump republican congresswoman who
has been heavily defended and propped up
by the former one-term president donald
trump
a marjorie taylor green and aguero
previously worked on anti-immigration
issues they've been to pro-trump rallies
together
and i previously told you about videos
in which marjorie taylor green
referred to aguero as amazing
and as a friend and as cnn has reported
aguero has called marjorie taylor green
quote
one of my closest friends so now we know
he was there
we know that a marjorie taylor green
ally was in the riots
now what well the next question is
actually one that goes back to a prior
question that we still don't have an
answer to
were there current pro-trump members of
congress
who were involved in discussions about
the plans for the trump riot ahead of
time
were some of these pro-trump congress
people not merely
indifferent to the riots not merely
supportive of the riots after the fact
but were any of them
actually proactive uh participants
in the planning of the january 6th trump
riots
we don't know the answer yet there are
already
investigations into certain tours of the
capital that happened
in the days leading up to the riots and
we're still trying to figure out
why would there be any tours since the
capital has been restricted
because of the pandemic that doesn't
make any sense so many more questions
remain unanswered i guess is the way i
would put it now
the position of the right continues to
be
a sort of conflicting mix of talking
points these were
fake trumpists who rioted on january 6th
but at the same time we heard from ron
johnson
that if they were real trumpists they
weren't a threat to
anybody like him because they are
patriots who wanted
what's good for the country which
conflicts with they weren't actually
trumpists
um and they also had no plans to do
anything wrong
except they did because just being there
was a crime
you know how the right loves to say
undocument
the all undocumented immigrants are
criminal aliens
because it's illegal to be here for them
being here
undocumented is a crime why does it
matter
what they were doing at the capitol
forcing your way inside is destruction
of property and trespassing
as they like to say about undocumented
immigrants it's a
crime just to be there under those
circumstances but of course
very different rules apply to pro-trump
insurrectionists than to undocumented
people
coming over the u.s mexico border so the
next question is
will we i mean it's a question for you
it's a question for us to think about
will there be any definitive linking
of these pro-trump members of congress
to the planning and organization of the
january sixth riots and there's a lot of
speculation on this
there are investigations going on and
then
the the sort of follow-up question is if
there are pro-trump congress people
linked to the planning of the riots
will there be any consequences because
if anything has become
the sort of default norm in the united
states political
world it's that for many elected
officials
particularly republicans because their
own party is unwilling to hold them
accountable
there's just no consequences for things
that in the past there would be
significant consequences for
let me know what you think and of course
we'll continue following the
investigations
bad news for donald trump's former
personal
attorney rudy giuliani he may be facing
felony charges the website law and crime
is
now reporting that fulton county georgia
district attorney
fannie willis is reportedly looking into
whether her office can prosecute
rudy giuliani over a series of false
statements and conspiracy
theories that he was peddling during a
session
of the georgia state legislature late
last year
remember that tour that rudy did during
which he ultimately got coronavirus
where he was doing all sorts of events
at state legislatures
filing court complaints and all sorts of
different things
according to the daily beast with an
anonymous source
familiar with the matter willis is
researching
whether georgia code 161020
could be applied to the things that rudy
said before a georgia senate panel
in december of 2020. rudy told
a republican group of legislators quote
you were the final arbiter of who the
electors should be
and whether the process is fair the
other way to look at it
is it's your responsibility if a false
and fraudulent court
is account is submitted to the united
states government
and it's clear the count you have right
now is false
and what rudy was claiming was that
there were 231 000 odd ballots
together with no return record at all
that a hundred and thirty four thousand
votes were thrown out
but quote you kept 96 000 votes where
there was no return
record for them rudy implying that there
were
phantom votes and of course
all of these claims were very quickly
debunked even by
republican elected officials in georgia
but the question is whether rudy
giuliani here
may have committed a felony by
intentionally
misleading senators as well as the
people of georgia
and the united states perpetuating the
disinformation and under the law in
question
it is a crime to knowingly and willfully
falsify conceal or cover up
a material fact or to make a false
fictitious or fraudulent statement or
representation
before any department or agency of state
government
now in general these laws are used to
prosecute people who are interviewed
during investigations
and they say things that are untrue
knowingly untrue
and it makes it similar to you're not
allowed to lie
to federal agents and there are other
trump associates at the federal level
who have been wrapped up
because of that it's not typically used
in this exact
way but what rudy giuliani did in the
aftermath of the 2020 election as well
as sydney powell and jenna ellis and
others
is also not typical so there's no
question that this would be
it would be significant if the d.a chose
to go after rudy giuliani on this it
would be
a big expansion of investigation
uh by district attorneys with within
a state but certainly uh rudy giuliani
here could be
in a significant legal issue and listen
even if it doesn't go very far
the possibility of it going places is
likely to lead
to to require rudy giuliani
to be well represented by council and
maga making attorneys get attorneys
everybody around trump needing to hire
their own attorneys
even trump's own lawyers now if it ever
comes to it
i am completely convinced
that rudy is going to sort of adopt the
position
of sydney powell and tucker carlson
which is no
reasonable person would believe what
rudy said to be true
doesn't necessarily mean rudy was lying
but it certainly suggests that as fox
news lawyers have argued when tucker
says things that don't
occu correspond to the facts it's
because
it's hyperbole it's a performance it's
an entertainment program he shouldn't be
expected to be saying things
that are factual when sydney powell said
dominion voting systems this
and uh you know electors that and all of
this other stuff
that nobody should have believed that
what she was saying was factual really
because she sounded pretty serious when
she was saying it
i assume that that's the defense that
rudy would take
and what's amazing is i've already heard
a reaction
to that from trumpists who are saying
listen
sidney powell still believes that it was
stolen
and sidney powell was serious when she
said the election was stolen
this is just an election defense saying
no one really could have believed that
as a legal defense is just a legal
defense so she doesn't get in trouble
we all know the trumpists and q anon
people are saying
we all know that the election was stolen
and she was telling the truth but now
she's
only saying this to get out of legal
trouble now what's interesting is
obviously the election wasn't stolen but
it's certainly
sydney powell seems bonkers enough that
she really may believe the election was
stolen and she really may be using this
legal defense
to get out of legal trouble that's
possible but that doesn't make it true
as we now know there is no evidence
whatsoever
that the 2020 election was stolen we
have a voicemail number
and that number is 219 to
david p uh here's a really nice
voicemail
this is the occasional nice voicemail
um and it's from a therapist who says
the show
the david pakman show to her is like
therapy for therapists what a nice
message to send take a listen to this
hey pac-man my name is leanna smith i
am a mental health therapist here in
charlotte north carolina
and i just wanted to reach out to you
first of all to
um commend you on the spectacular job
that you do every day
thank you when i come home from work put
on youtube
i put your show on any of your
recordings and i just come to realize
that
you are my therapy so pacman is the
therapy to the therapist wow
i just wanted to share that with you i
think that is hilarious but um
no you do actually um enlighten me a lot
and i appreciate um all the viewpoints
that you share throughout your show
different aspects on everything you um
actually bring value
to a lot of the crap that's going on in
the world today so i just wanted to send
a shout out
to thank you um from charlotte north
carolina
keep doing your thing packing wow
uh a perfect voicemail if i've ever
heard one
i really do appreciate that many
mental health professionals are in the
david pakman show audience
ranging from social workers to
psychologists
l a l mhcs and
uh psychiatrists even it's a it's a
broad range of mental health
professionals and i really do appreciate
that we have a great bonus show for you
today
it appears as though vice president
kamala harris
is going to be leading white house
efforts to stem
migration at the border what will that
look like
we also now are seeing 12 attorneys
general calling on facebook and twitter
to remove
anti-vaxxers from their services
where will that go and lastly remember
how donald trump led
let that wacky right-wing network oan
into the white house that is now joe
biden's problem
and it's very interesting what is going
on so all of those stories
and more including previews of next
week's show vacation on today's bonus
show
you can get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member at
joinpacman.com and
very important okay we're off next week
the show's not cancelled don't worry
i know that every time we take some time
off i get about 100 emails saying what
happened there's no show
is it cancelled what we're just taking a
week off next week we'll be here
tomorrow i'll be live today for the joe
biden press conference
but next week we are off alright so
bonus show in moments
show tomorrow no show next week
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman